this legal
[Music]
I think we're gonna hallucinate and see
fairies this fairy has a big old butt
get him with those curves
this looks like an erotic potion do you
mind a little more lemony peppermint
black licorice that's why I thought it
was Jaeger we're supposed to pour the
Absinthe up to a bubble let's put a
sugar cube each when this is like
witchcraft
well maybe went a little over the bubble
but yeah you know it is a Tuesday we
open this tab onto this sugar cube let
the games begin
Oh Dora whoa what a beautiful beverage
machine can I like touch it
the Europeans are classier drinking than
we are bloop bloop bloop bloop the
equivalent of this for us is just like
shotgunning a beer imagine you're like
in another country meet me for absinthe
watch the water drip talk about Sunday
it's putting me in a relaxed state kind
of makes me have to peel a little yeah
got that heavy flow he will cut that
heavy flow Oh am I so milky mine looks
like lemonade alcohols a cloud I've gone
to the rim that's how like my dreams
fill it to the rim I mean I want to take
this to a picnic and enjoy it with
someone I love I think it's cool that
there's like this intricate drinking
system yeah so much decorum should you
talk about politics that's good
this is a lot like seeming Lyme looks
like pee
Cheers stairs to three o'clock in the
afternoon
oh I like that is very pleasant I think
I just screwed chest hair yeah let's go
this is kind of scary it's so good
tastes like a slightly licorice iced tea
it's like spa water you're tugging like
apertium where's the ferry to tribute
rate you're saying trippy trade cuz it's
gonna make us trip oh look at her she's
drunk already I'm not am I gonna trip
balls look at there's a ferry right
there that's gonna be us Chris in like
ten minutes
this is I'm gonna go back to work just
like party over here [ __ ] what thing is
both of us are pretty high alcohol tars
whoa hey I'm starting to feel like yeah
oh my go I think the business here a
straw is just a urethra I'm in another
realm I'm starting to feel a little bit
whimsical when did that speak of you
know I'm drooling
I have cottonmouth right now what is
happening kind of feel it forward in my
face in my hands feel different that
makes me feel nice though Oh your face
looks so soft great no what is happening
in my eyes right now is so small my
editing is gonna go really well I'm just
like high-energy though
oh I'm just concerned about my eyes
being like this permanently light is do
you not feel like a one oh yeah so I
started looking at that one very like
photosensitive right now I've literally
been looking at this one spot in the
room this entire filming you like that
look people in the eyes and all laughing
okay I know that I seem stressed but I'm
really a happy girl I love everybody
whom also go we talked about this glass
about this glass oh this glass your lord
it is exquisite
shut up on some ego so they go away now
on a Tuesday buh buh buh buh buh buh bah
bah boom hey the Strickland's got to go
down this one it's just like a ball hang
in there
go down she's talking to the water
droplet man this is crazy it was illegal
to produce but he did it anyway I feel
like I've discovered my reflection for
the first time like I looked in the
mirror and I said who are really what
but there's no mirror is this alcohol
immediately I feel like I took three
shots a whole night out in five minutes
what is that science I want to do this
again I'm like kind of disappointed it's
3 o'clock on a Tuesday drive safe and be
responsible yeah and make sure that you
shave your pubes if you're gonna drink
this it's crazy to me to think that
people drink this as like the regular
alcohol in other countries you people
are are crazy
mm-hmm but correct you know when you
start like looking at someone ad start
to look like through them I like looking
through the camera like at the people
watching there's nothing in turn uh I
think I can feel you